euh on va passer à l'invité du soir on
va parler encore de ce complément
d'enquête hein je sais pas si vous êtes
au courant mais ça chauffe chez France
télévision les images de gerérard
pardieu euh ça pose pose beaucoup de
questions euh voilà on va en parler un
peu plus tard avec Maître Assous mais on
va en parler tout de suite hein
d'ailleurs avec Maître Jérémy Assous qu'
est déjà 20h58 euh et euh aujourd'hui
les images de Gérard pardieux en Corée
du Nord avec notamment cette histoire
avec la petite fille on y voyait Gérard
de par Dieu y tenir des propos à
caractère sexuel concernant une petite
fille ces images ont rapidement fait
polémique Yan MOX a déclaré être sûr à
99 % que Gérard pardieu ne parlait pas
d'une petite fille certains ont annoncé
un trafic des images et bien aujourd'hui
euh il il semblerait que euh cette
hypothèse euh soit privilégiée euh
Jérémy Assous l'avocat de Yan MOX va
nous en dire un peu plus avant tout on
RG regarde euh cette image qui a fait
tant parler et on va vous dire s'il y a
eu euh bien sûr montage ou pas euh ce
serait euh incroyable hein bien entendu
regardez les femmes adoreent faire du
cheval elles ont le le clitau qui frotte
sur le ha le pomau de la SE et là ça ah
ben c'est c'est des grosses
il va même jusqu'à sexualiser
une fillette d'une dizaine d'années si
jamais galope elle
jouit c'est bien ma fifille continue tu
vois elle se gratte
là tu regardes ch pourquoi tu montes pas
cheval ça fait du bien tu
saisuse guillaume est revenu
heureusement pas toiurais
d ma tellement énervé je suis mis sur
toi tu sais mais c'est lui en fait je
comme ça metstoi à ma place et regarde
ça toute la journée tu vas voir tu vas
voir tu vas voir si tu dev pas nerveux
merci jéréous merci maî jé d'être avec
nous avocat et
là a un gros problème quand même ce soir
merci d'être avec nous déjà il paraît
que tout le monde vous voulez ce soir
par que tout le monde voulait vous
inviter non il il y a eu un certain
nombre d'invitations mais il me semblait
normal de répondre à la vôtre en
priorité du fait que vous étiez les
premiers pas les seuls mais les premiers
à avoir donné le point de vue de Yan
moax et de la défense de gerérrard de
pardieu et
de considérer que peut-être il y avait
une difficulté peut-être que les propos
qu' prête à gerérardo pardieu qu' a dit
qu'il a tenu mais pas à l'encontre de
cette jeune fille à l'encontre d'une
autre personne et dans un cadre très
spécifique à savoir que Gard de pardieu
avait été convié en Corée du Nord grâce
à et à la demande de icari c'est une
société de production qui est dirigée
par Anthony Dufour et c'était dans le
cadre d'un long métrage
cinématographique et donc il a été
considéré il a été mis en œuvre avec Yan
moax un projet de fiction où il Yan MOX
a eu l'idée de filmer pendant 7 jours
Gérard pardieu en Corée du Nord ce
serait un peu l'idée c'était un peu
mamouth en Corée du Nord ou Obélix en
Corée du Nord c'est-à-dire une personne
totalement incontrôlable extrêmement
libre dans le pays le plus contrôlé et
le plus fermé du monde et donc l'idée
c'était de que Gérard pardieu joue son
propre rôle en l'exagérant et en donnant
énormément de matière au réalisateurs
qui y max pour après en faire un long
métrage de fiction ce qui est très
important c'est que lorsque vous m'avez
invité fin décembre on avait pas pu
réunir un certain nombre de documents
puisqueque énormément de documents nous
manquaient puisque ikcari les gardait
par devir soi mais on a pu reconstituer
certain nombre de choses la première
chose c'est que on a un très grand
nombre de mails de Anthony Dufour qui
remercie Yan max et qui considère que ce
film puisqu'on parle bien de film est
une œuvre de fiction que c'est un long
métrage cinématographique qui est
destiné en priorité aux plateformes il
cite notamment Netflix et ensuite les
salles et les différents
festivaux c'est une fiction c'est pour
mettre le voilà pour mettre l'accent sur
le fait que Gérard pardieu était Gérard
pardieu mais pour vous il jouait un rôle
mais il jouait son propre rôle quand je
dis Gérard de par Dieu joue son propre
rôle c'est le contrat qui dit ça
c'est-à-dire queil est convenu entre duf
le producteur et Yan max que Gérard que
Yan Max est l'auteur le réalisateur du
long métrage cinématographique que
Gérard de pardieu a le rôle principal et
qu'il faut absolument acquérir les
droits d'interprétation de Gérard de
pardieu en Corée du Nord vous pouvez pas
y aller avec un scénario c'est interdit
c'est comme ça donc ce qui était convenu
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que reconnaît
Anthony Dufour dans l'article du Monde
de ce matin ce qui était convenu c'est
que on y a sur place et on fait
énormément de mise en situation et que
ensuite grâce aux 18h de rushche au 20h
de rushche on puisse dans le cadre d'un
montage en faire une œuvre rajouter des
personnag rajouter des bandes de son
rajouter des vois off et cetera c'est ce
qui s'est passé et il était convenu que
Anthony Dufour merde met ce film à
l'écran il se trouve que Anthony Dufour
qui est loin d'être courageux après
avoir été extrêmement enthousiaste de
2018 parce que tout ça et le tournage
date de 2018 il est extrêmement
enthousiaste en 2019 en 2020 mais Gérard
de pardieu est mis en examen le 16
décembre 2020 pour les agressions
sexuelles à partir de ce moment-là
Anthony Dufour a un énorme problème
c'est que il se dit mon film ne vaut
plus rien j'ai investi un peu d'argent
je ne peux plus rien en faire parce que
qui va vouloir distribuer le film avec
de par Dieu le film est mort et donc il
traîne et il dit à Yan wax si tu veux
récupérer tes bandes il y a pas de
difficulté tu me donnes 68000 € j'ai
investi 68000 € faut me les rendre toi
tu crois en ton film moi je veux me
retirer c'est son droit le plus strict
il y a de moi c'est tout à fait d'accord
mais il dit voilà vous m'avez annoncé un
budget de 68000 € dans lequel il y a les
billets d'avion de Gérard pardieu il y a
le prix du montage il y a le prix des
caméramans des preneurs de son donc
c'est c'est bel et bien une équipe de
tournage qui qui a été envoy en Corée du
Nord et Yan max tout à fait normalement
dit et tout ça c'est prouvé he tout ça
on a des documents et ils sont déjà au
tribunal à partir du moment où vous me
demandez de vous rembourser 60000 €
merci de nous donner justificatif et là
Anthony Dufour ne donne rien parce qu'il
n'en a pas de justificatif ou en tout
cas peut-être qu'il en a mais pas à
hauteur de 68000 € donc il y a moi qui
se dit moi je rembourse à hauteur des
dépenses que vous avez faites ou alors
on est coproducteur vous prenez prenez
votre risque et on se développe et là
non mais c'est ça je termine parce que
c'est très important il se trouve que
les
discussions s'étir et dur jusqu'en
2023 et en
2023 Anthony Dufour qui est parfaitement
d'accord pour les vendre et dit je vous
donnerai les justificatifs plus tard
change à partir de juillet 2023 change
son fusil d'épaule et dit bon je vais
pas vous donner justification dit je
vais pas vous le vendre 78000 € je vous
vends une option ça coûte juste 10000 €
comme ça vous pouvez récupérer vos rush
vous pouvez récupérer continuer votre
montage parce qu'il y a quand même un un
un projet qui de 2h30 qui a été fait et
il dit mais à une condition c'est que je
puisse conserver l'exploitation des
images sur lesquelles apparaît Jard de
pardieu bien évidemment il a de moi dit
non c'est impossible déjà Gérard de paru
ne voudra pas c'est dans le cadre d'une
fiction il faut les exploiter dans le
cadre d'une fiction et là jusqu'au 5
décembre 2023 ça a été diffusé le 7 il
dit écoutez je vous les donne je vous
rends tout votre matière tout votre
filme à une condition encore une fois
que je puisse exploiter les images
quelle figure pour complément d'enquête
ou et qu'est-ce qui s'est passe c'est
que on sait pertinemment qu'il a signé
avec complément d'enquête été printemps
été 2023 qu'il a vendu ses images quoi
il a vendu ces images mais bien sûr
puisque ça c'est ça c'est une info c'est
une grosse info mais c'est c'est très
simple il aurait vendu ces images il les
a vendu la déontologie puisque Tristan
warlex a dit qu'il avait respectecter
scrupuleusement la déontologie et voilà
la déontologie et la Charre du syndicat
des journalistes rappelle que un
journaliste ne peut pas acquérir en
contrepartie de versement de somme
d'argent une source ou des images là ce
qui s'est passé c'est que Anthony Dufour
les seules choses qui é intéressantes
dans ce complément d'enquête c'est bien
évidemment cette séquence ces images là
Antony Dufour ne pouvait pas les vendre
directement parce que France Télévision
on dit mais non on peut pas acheter soit
vous nous les donnerz mais dans ces
cas-là on va faire nous notre enquête on
va appeler ne serait- que il a MOX on va
voir dans quel cadre ces images ont été
filmées si on leur dit que c'est une
fiction c'est fini on peut pas les
exploiter donc ce que fait Anthony
Dufour avec la complicité de France
Télévision c'est qu'ils font un espèce
de montage assez grossier qui a fait
illusion un mois c'est quoi le montage
c'est que ils disent bon ben voilà on va
pas vous verser de l'argent pour ces
images mais on va vous verser 140000 € à
peu près entre 120 et 140000000 € mais
ils vont nous communiquer le contrat ils
seront contraints non pas pour acheter
les images mais pour que vous produisiez
le sujet ce fameux sujet la chute d'un
OC puisque vous avez bien compris que le
producteur de la chute d'un og est iari
film ah bah oui c'est et là ils ont fait
une faute très grave et une faute pénale
c'est que le fait de décaler la bande
son avec l'image puisque ses propos ne
sont pas tenus à
proposors y a la c'est très important
très important ça est- les images sont
truqués ou pas alors écoutez
ils ont réussi un tour de pass-p
exceptionnel faut reconnaître qu'au
niveau de com France Télévision ont été
assez bon et complment si si si puis que
tout le monde est tombé est tombé dans
le panneau pour mettre un terme à la
polémique et c'est aussi ce qui est
écrit dans l'article du Monde ils ont
dit nous avons fait authentifier ces
images et ces rush par un Hissier alors
déjà la première chose à savoir c'est
qu'un Hissier n'auutentifie rien du tout
il constate alors que luisser constater
que Gérard deieu dit ça à un
bien évidment il suffit je vois pas
pouro ils ont dépensé quelques centaines
d'Uros à partir du moment où ils ont dit
non on a montré l'ensemble des roches à
luuissier et dans ces conditions il a pu
certifier que ce queil disait il le dis
bien à propos de la fiette immédiatement
tout le monde a pris pour argent
comptant cette déclaration et a
considéré que c'était la vérité deux
choses la première chose très importante
ce constat personne l'a vu il ref refuse
de le communiquer on l'a demandé par
l'intermédiaire de différents
journalistes il refuse de communiquer
mais j'ai appris tout à l'heure que la
police a qui fait une enquête sur ce
dossier dans le cadre de l'instruction
pour agression sexuelle a exigé tout
comme elle a demandé à ce que y Mo soit
entendu et qui donne sa version dans le
cadre des conditions d'enregistrement ce
qui va faire bien évidemment elle a
exigé également de la part de France
Télévision
et d'Ikar film qui communique les rush
et le constat et C derniers ont refusé
ils ont refusé en avoquant le secret des
sources sauf que ce n'est pas une source
puisque eux-même et dphin Hernot très
honnêtement a déclaré dans le monde que
à Ti exceptionnel puisqu'il y avait
énormément de demandes et a quand même
le président de la République qui s'est
positionné sur ce sujet elle acceptait
de qu'un Nuissier puisse regarder ses
images à partir du moment où un nuier le
regarde pourquoi puisquil y a toujours
cette polémique d'autres ne les
regarderaient pas mais surtout pourquoi
il ne communique pas le constat il ique
tout simplement pas parce que ce constat
constate ce qu'on a vu à la télévision
mais de ne montre rien par contre ce qui
est très important c'est que l'article
du Monde dit et le journaliste donc Krug
qui a fait ce long papier dans le Monde
Magazine enfin le M m m le monde il dit
ce que Yan Max a toujours soutenu que il
a vu lui le film de Yan max il dit bien
que c'est tout sa un documentaire et il
dit il y a aussi ce passage dans le
puisque c'est une séquence très
importante puisque là y avait demandé à
pardieu de d'être extrêmement
provocquant il dit on a les paroles et
les propos de Gérard pardieu sauf qu'il
les tient pas à l'encontre de la
fillette il les tient à
l'encontre de la jeune fille alors ça
c'est très grave et là vous savez il y a
une chose qui est très simple et j'ai
demandé à y s me l'a écrit oui écoutez
que vous vous souveniez plus puisque
vous nous dites du 99 % comme vous
l'avez rappelé que il n'a pas tenu ses
propos d' petit je veux bien qu'on
puisse plus être sûr 100 % c'était quand
même il y a 6 ans aujourd'hui il y a
c'est difficile d'avoir une certitude
par contre il y a une chose que vous ne
pouvez pas oublier c'est est-ce que vous
avez manipulé la bande son pour faire un
décalage avec l'image ouais ça c'est un
acte positif on s'en souvient il me dit
je l'ai jamais fait donc à partir de ce
moment-là grâce au journalistes du Monde
on a la
certitude que les images qui ont été
montré à la tdvisions sur complément
d'enquête sont totalement truqué et ce
qui est très intéressant c'est qu'à
partir de c'est extrêmement grave une
infration pénale mais mais ce qui est
très important et c'est très simple
c'est que l'auteur principal c'est comme
en matière de diffamation l'auteur
principal du montage de l'infraction de
montage illicite et j'invite c'est
l'article
226- 8 du code pénal pour nos amis de
icari je le fais gagner un peu de temps
comme ça ils peuvent aller directement
voir l'article l'auteur principal c'est
bien évidemment France Télévision comme
en matière d'inamation c'est le
directeur de publication mais les
complices de cette infraction sont les
coréalisateurs bien sûr et là il y a
trois coréalisateurs il y a Damen furret
Daniel Viala et Emmanuel Bert et ces
personnes-là vont se défendre puisquelle
risque une condamnation et elles vont
être poursuiv dansant le tribunal
correctionnel ces personneslà vont dire
mais attendez moi j'ai travaillé avec
les matières qu'on m'a donné et pour se
défendre sauf si elles ont envie d'être
condamné elles vont bien évidemment
communiquer les matières qu' et là on va
le voir donc il y a une manière très
simple de mettre un terme à cette
polémique soit Mo dit n'importe quoi et
dans ces cas-là communiqueznous les Roch
puisque vous savez alors le
téléspectateur sait peut-être pas mais
vous pourrez confirmer dans n'importe
quelle caméra de ce type de caméra quel
Lang il y a ce qu'on appelle un time
code oui et un time code pour l'image il
y a un time code pour le son c'est ça on
voit si en montage ou pas exactement on
ne peut pas tricher donc plutôt que de
faire appel à un huissier faites appel à
un expert un expert audiovisuel et
j'invite surtout et c'est avec c'est pas
sans plaisir que j'invite l'arcom sur ce
plateau quand même de parler un peu de
l'arcom de veiller à ce qu'elle puisse
faire une enquête elle en a le pouvoir
et donc l'arcom va pouvoir demander à
France Télévision qui aura obligation de
communiquer l'intégralité des roches
qu'elle n'a pas puisque c'est une
production externe donc elle va le
demander à Ikari puisquil on garanti de
bonne fa qui va le communiquer et là on
s'apercevra de quoi que depuis le début
ce cher Anthony Dufour puisqu'il
n'arrivait pas à retomber sur ses pieds
ou à retrouver ses quelques denniers
qu'il a dépensé n'a pas hésité à trahir
Yan max en vendant ces images qui
étaient destiné à un long maîtage
cinématographique dans lequel de joue
son propre rôle et à les présenter au
public à France Télévision comme des
informations d'intérêt général et ça ça
s'appelle un abus de confiance c'est
aussi une infraction pénale et il en
répondra devant les juridictions
correctionnelles maître on dit que cette
affaire serait suivie en plus au plus
haut niveau aujourd'hui les révélations
que vous faites ce so soir en direct à
21h13 sur C8 vous vous êtes conscient
que là là c'est tout France Télévision
qui peut vaciller c'est pas que
complément d'enquêteis
V extrve c'est extrêmement grave puisque
on a lyché un homme qui a plus donné
qu'il a reçu de la France quand même
alors après qui est un imm non non mais
je suis pas le conseil de Gard deieu il
a d'excellents avocats il a pas de
difficultés
toute la polémique sur de Part Dieu
toute la polémique sur de par Dieu vient
de cette phrase c'est cette phrase qui
lui a fait énormément et
qui à partir du moment où attribu cette
phrase il est disqualifié socialement
des femmes il a il est il devient
inaudible ça a été ça a été ça a été le
déclencheur sur ce
sur toujours est-il que il y a des
personnes qui sont peut-être un peu
mieux informé que nous en tout cas que
moi notamment le président de la
République oua le président de la
République a dit à juste titre qu'il y
avait une polémique là c'est plus une
polémique il y a des procès il y a du
contentieux et ils peuvent y mettre un
terme très facilement en donnant
l'intégralité des
Roch le président de la République s'est
littéralement fait insulter puisque j'ai
vu sur un plateau que certaines
personnes lui demandaient expressément
de se taire alors que il n'a juste fait
qu'une seule chose il a rappelé un
principe de base c'est la présomption
d'innocence et il a quand même rappelé
que c'est fait et la version qui était
donnée
par complément d'enquête était contesté
aujourd'hui elle est totalement
contestée donc donnez-nous le constat on
va voir ce qui contient donnez-nous les
rushes donnez-nous le film de Yan max
que Monsieur Krug a vu et c'est un film
qui ne peut pas disparaître puisque j'ai
moi 44 attestations de personnes qui
l'ont vu parceque des producteurs l'ont
vu un certain nombre de publics l'a vu
et il y avait un lien qui part de chez
Dufour j'ai à peu près 65 ma de un lien
vimao qui de duf qui envoie le film aux
uns et aux autres donc qu'on puisse nous
public vous public et nous juristes et
avocat Dex réétablir la vérité la vérité
est de notre côté d'accord et les
condamnations seront pour eux et les
condamnations vont être extrêmement
lourdes puisque làous dit-nous ce qui
risque dites-nous ce qu' risque alors en
ce qui concerne le montage licite la la
peine est très mesurée puisque c'est
15000 € un an de prison en ce qui
concerne l'ABU de confiance c'est un peu
plus sévère c'est le recette deabut de
confiance c'est en bande organisé non
mais au-delà du juridique de l'aspect
juridique mais mais mais mais monsieur
Dufour ne mérite plus de diriger une
société de production et pour France
Télévision bien évidemment il vont il va
falloir en tirer les conséquen pourquoi
parce que que France Télévision a été
dupé et été dupé par un de ses
producteurs externes ça arrive véf ça
arrive ça arrive malheureusement
régulièrement non non mais la différence
c'est que ils ont couvert ou la méthode
de
Luissier Tristan warlex a dit moi il y a
je rapporte la preuve que tout ce que a
été diffusé est conforme à la réalité à
la vérité parce que j'ai l'issier sauf
que là ils ont automatiquement demander
à la production à Ikari donnez-nous tous
les roches donc soit ils se sont
contentés oui de trois extraits et ils
ont couvert cette infraction ils ont
couvert ce détournement et dans ces CASL
il est normal qu'ils en répondent soit
en fait compte pour résumer c'est simple
ils sont complices ou incompétents faut
choisir mais dans tous les cas il y aura
une San dans tous les cas merci maître
Jérémy Assous d'avoir été avec nous
c'est c'est on l'aanancé une bombe ce
soir bien sûr on va reparler lundi en
tout cas merci d'avoir été avec nous et
nous avoir fait ces révélations
incroyable en direct ce soir tout de
suite c'est bienvenue au monastère sur
C8 merci à
tous